todo mundo no mundo Albert Einstein Bill
Gates Neymar todo mundo na terra já deu
uma mordida num sabonete só para ver
como é que é e se arrependeu porque não
tem no mundo Mentira o gosto do sabonete
da boca da pessoa o sabonete líquido ó
travou botou na bolsa é fácil Se
transportar um negócio sensacional aí
vou usar Abrir botei ali e tal usei
guardei show o sabonete barra não o
sabonete barra já está lá no lugar dele
é ali e se ele tá ali é porque alguém
usou já usou aonde hein em todo lugar do
corpinho dela E tu também quer usar em
todo lugar do teu corpo aí tá indo no
banheiro pô esqueci o sabonete me
empresta o sabonete aí o cara vem com um
desse aí eu uso qualquer lugar do meu
corpo no meu rosto possível até lá pro
meus dentes aí outras situação tu fala e
me empresta o sabonete a pessoa te
empresta um desse tá tão pequenininho já
foi grande passado e muitos lugares